sans l'italie il n'y a pas d'europe
voilà les mots de mario draghi lors de
son discours au parlement ce mercredi
sans surprise l'ex président de la
banque centrale européenne se tourner
vers bruxelles et appelle à une plus
grande solidarité entre pays membres
pour sortir de la crise économique et
sanitaire soutenir ce gouvernement
signifie partager l'irréversibilité du
choix de l'euro signifie partager de la
perspective d'une union européenne plus
intégrée qui aboutira en budget public
commun capable de soutenir les états
membres durant les périodes de récession
problèmes d'approvisionnement pour les
vaccins fermeture unilatérale des
frontières
l'europe n'a pas été un exemple de
solidarité face à la pandémie
source d'espoir pour rome le plan de
relance européen adopté par lieu le 21
juillet dernier dont l'italie sera le
principal bénéficiaire
une aide précieuse pour un pays jadis
très europhile qui a peu à peu perdu son
engouement européen membre fondateur de
la ceca signataire du traité de rome
constituant la communauté économique
européenne de 1957
l'italie est historiquement très lié à
l'union européenne
ce gouvernement est né dans le sillage
de l'adhésion de notre pays à l'union
européenne en tant que membre fondateur
et en tant que protagoniste de
l'alliance atlantique dans le sillage
des grandes démocraties occidentales en
défense de leurs principes et valeurs
inaliénables
mais en 2001 l'arrivée de silvio
berlusconi au pouvoir change la donne
l' influence italienne au sein de l'ue
eux se dégrade et l'instabilité
chronique de ces gouvernements mine sa
crédibilité à
l'international souvent mise à l'écart
lors des négociations l'italie et ses
habitants glisse peu à peu vers
l'euroscepticisme
en témoigne la création en juillet 2020
du parti ital exit prenant une sortie de
lieux tandis que le pays traverse sa
pire récession depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale cette crise pourrait menacer
directement les autres pays membres
le défi aujourd'hui pour mario draghi
fédérer les puissances européennes
si l'homme échoue les populistes seront
bien au rendez vous pour s'assurer que
le projet européen ne soit plus que de
l'histoire ancienne